in may 2009 7 astronauts flew to the
Hubble Space Telescope aboard space
shuttle Atlantis bringing to the ailing
observatory new batteries a new camera
and spare parts to fix broken hardware
it was the fifth servicing mission to
Hubble and the final planned repair
opportunity for the telescope the
astronauts brought more than replacement
parts with them however they also
carried an IMAX camera to space to
document their mission just a month
before Hubble's 20th birthday comes
hubble 3d a new documentary film
directed by Tony Myers here to discuss
the film is Tony Myers and the missions
commander Scott Altman thank you both
for joining us our pleasure so Tony what
about this mission appealed to you as a
filmmaker well first of all it I wanted
to make a film about Hubble that told
the life story of Hubble or as much of
it as we could do in our timeframe and
of course this was the final service
mission and I knew that there were a lot
of interesting spacewalks and really
challenging we like the most challenging
spacewalks ever to be performed we're
going to happen on it so I knew it was
going to be exciting good and in Scott
this is your fourth trip in space was
there anything different for you this
time in terms of feeling added pressure
because the scientific stakes were so
high and everyone was watching from the
ground well I think that's the key point
we knew on my last mission that there
were future servicing missions planned
and while there's always a challenge to
get stuff done you think well someone
else could finish if we had to on this
one we knew it was the final trip last
chance Hubble's been such an incredible
instrument we all wanted to do as much
as we could to put it in his greatest
shape as it could be for it to continue
its voyage of discovery Antonio if you
would talk about some of the challenges
that you faced as a filmmaker for whom
so many of the shots are out of your
control you're on the ground the
telescope is in the hands of the
astronauts I'm sorry that the cameras in
the hands with astronauts we do train
about eight months out from the flight
and we develop a scene list kind of wish
list of shots based on our observations
of there
for the space walks in the pool and the
challenges really are only the timeline
we of course there's a sunrise and
sunset every 90 minutes and we know that
if they get behind on this tightly
scripted script then our best shots may
wind up being in the dark where we can't
shoot but we also know that's a
possibility so we do contingency
planning in the list as well and no I
totally trust them we train them to be
cinematographers and directors and we
also say if an alien flies up and puts
his face in the window just because it's
not on the list don't not shoot it you
know it's your the directors and
ultimately the decisions are in your
hands I see and in terms of working in
3d how does that change that process of
shooting film is there an actual
technical difference well there is a
technical difference of a big one in the
case of the camera we flew in the cargo
bay which is the imax 3d cargo bay
camera that carries a mile of film it's
a single load you can't change it out in
the vacuum and that yields eight minutes
of 3d film that's because it's shooting
both the left eye and the right eye for
3d that are normally on two strips on
one piece of film and so that's not a
lot eight minutes you have to plan it
out very carefully all the footage in
the film that we see that's the the
payload Bay camera that's taken from
eight minutes of raw footage that's
correct Wow yeah yeah a lot of pressure
not to leave too much on the cutting
room yeah no no absolutely they did a
bad punt but a stellar job and Tony uh
in the film there's some very wonderful
three dimensional fly throughs if you
just talk a little bit about how those
were made and how much emphasis was put
on keeping those scientifically accurate
I wanted to do two things I wanted to
explore a phenomenon that was familiar
to most people in the night sky even if
they're only part time
you know stargazers and that turned out
to be the Orion Nebula because most
people are familiar with Orion's belt
has something so I didn't wanted to to
start there and that also turned out to
be a very huge data set of Hubble's it's
actually when you combine the three
datasets that we used it's a billion
pixels worth of information and and so
that was one we used you know one for
the approach and then another data set
in in the interior for the trapezium
region where all that little baby solar
systems are and a third for the
accretion disk and we combined all of
those with a software program called
werder virtual director that allows you
to plot a flight path through the data
but it's all real data there there isn't
any you know just straight phony CGI in
there and the other the other concluding
sequence is one that I wanted to do to
try and convey in the simplest way
possible the scale of the universe and
so we in that when we fly from the milky
way out past Andromeda and then into the
Virgo cluster each time we pass
something we're going from a dozen
galaxies to 2,000 galaxies to a billion
galaxies so now in the film partly
because of the scale it's very easy to I
mean you and your fellow astronauts are
up on the screen and huge proportions
and you look like people who are about
to do something very serious and
possibly dangerous and that's not a side
of space flight that we get to see very
often is that you are there are there a
lot of nervous before you launch well I
think everybody is focused that's what I
talked folks I want to let's put our
game face on we're going out to do
something we want to make sure we're all
ready to meet this challenge head-on
it's going to take a lot of
concentration and focus to get up there
to get to the telescope and then to do
the spacewalks there's also a time to
relax and sort of recharge your
batteries
but I think it's important that we were
all ready to go and we got there and as
a veteran of four space flights would
you like to see the space shuttles life
extended beyond its its current for I
suppose for more lot more flights right
now the shuttle is an amazing amazing
vehicle its capability to be reusable to
take so much payload to orbit and bring
it home something that doesn't exist
anywhere else on the planet right now
transitions are always hard when you
move from something you know to
something that you don't but they're
also important to make progress to add
capability and I'm hopeful that we can
make that transition safely and find a
new path both to low-earth orbit and
Beyond to go back to the moon and on to
Mars and if space tourism becomes
reality any time soon would you be
pitching to get back up there you know
John Grunsfeld says he's happier in
space than anywhere else and you can see
it in the movie with the big grin on his
face when he comes in from a spacewalk I
feel that way a lot myself to it is an
incredible adventure and I'd love to be
a part of it again maybe next time take
my wife and kids along me too please
yeah me too which is a great thing about
imax is because it gives you the chance
to share that experience with people who
can't go my family to be there sitting
in the movie theater with my wife and
son sitting next to me was really a
special experience for me last night
thank you very much oh great it's been a
cue it's been a pleasure talking to both
of you enjoyed his father